[Music]
did I nail it or should I do it again
one more time
[Music]
hey I'm Hilary Duff
I'm Sutton Foster we are the cast I'm
younger and right here at BuzzFeed
and we're doing oh yeah truth or dare
version giant Jenga this is true
I would work backstage at dolls house
part 2 just so I could see everybody
accent ooh I would feel like the
backstage person who opens the door oh
yeah
dare
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's prank how nice is this she'll
answer
she'll the answer right you can you
could say like oh my god my mama you
want a pizza you're just getting drink
called on BuzzFeed right now I'm
terrified
oh god I'm not gonna look up here but I
don't buy it
do I do it like that no Oh Shh what do I
do
put in the middle oh sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
probably we have a big fight scene with
the one at the bonfire I think that was
really hard when we were like we were
drunk and we and me and emotional and we
had to yell at each other that whole
part was really hard not just I mean it
was and all the stuff that we had to go
through especially beginning of the
season was really hard because we were
like Fighting's oh another one's coming
out oh oh wow look at that truth but
deers are awful no don't I don't have
any plans for new music or tour this
year but there's always next year
well this one was loose but it seems
well it's really nervous with deers cuz
I'm not good at this stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
Sweeney Todd no it's completely it's my
type um it would be fun to do something
that's like unexpected yeah I don't know
so we have to do the thing and then they
put it in with the CG I like the mouse
ears and then they made us do it like
900 times
and he kind of like lost all personality
at that point it was like unless I was
like a pubescent teen like what am I
making me do this is invisible I think I
had like shot the beginning of listen
choir with all those bouncy balls and I
was like oh I can't wait it's like
Hillary with a lot of attitude I'm
really nervous about all of these shoes
I know these are boring
yeah yeah
yogurt oh yeah that's all you get desert
yogurt
social media that I'm ever I mean Disney
Channel things coming out those pretty
funny oh dear god oh god oh god
a long time all right she's a good
mother
she's nice smart she really has a great
sense of style she's funny
she's got she's very self-deprecating
kind she likes to eat she like eats like
a normal human being which i think is
exciting it's incredibly refreshing hey
guess what you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]